[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend die
interessante Frage der nächsten Zeit
wird sein ob sich nach dem Machtwort des
Kanzlers nun auch alle an die chefansage
halten und salopp gesagt von nun an Ruhe
im Karton herrscht oder ob das Ganze
bald von vorne losgeht eine Frage die
ich Christian Lindner vorhin gestellt
habe zu dem Interview kommen wir gleich
noch
bei näherer Betrachtung scheint nämlich
einigen FDP dann aufgefallen zu sein
dass sie im Atomstreit nicht ganz das
erreicht haben was sie eigentlich
wollten wohin gegen die Grünen die
gestern erstmal in eine Art Schockstarre
versanken inzwischen etwas weniger
unglücklich wirken dazu könnte
beigetragen haben dass der Kanzler sein
basta heute präzisierte aus Berlin
Daniel Botzen
als der Kanzler heute zu einem Termin in
Berlin erscheint stellt er auf Nachfrage
klar was gestern offen blieb bei seinem
sogenannten Machtwort nein es würden
keine neuen Brennstäbe mehr bestellt am
15 April nächsten Jahres sehr Schluss
mit Atomkraft in Deutschland endgültig
bis dahin aber blieben die drei noch
laufenden AKW in Betrieb das nun auf
jeden Fall
es wird jetzt nicht mehr geprüft ob das
wohl noch notwendig ist und es wird dann
tatsächlich entschieden es wird jetzt
produziert wir schicken also nicht
irgendwelche Kraftwerke in eine Reserve
um dann im Dezember nachdem das Gesetz
im November beschlossen zu sagen na sie
sollen schon laufen das machen wir
gleich gleich erscheint hier als sehr
dehnbarer Begriff viele Kritiker hatten
eine Entscheidung hierzu schon für
Monaten gefordert daran erinnerten den
Kanzler heute viele in Berlin ebenso
daran wie er mit seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz eigentlich umgehen
wollte oton Scholz im August es ist gut
dass ich sie habe aber natürlich nicht
in der Form dass ich jemandem einen
Brief schreibe bitte Herr Minister
machen sie das folgende gestern dann
doch ein solcher Brief mit
Handlungsanweisung und mit freundlichen
Grüßen ganz so überraschend sei der für
alle Adressaten aber nicht gekommen
mutmaß der Oppositionsführer dafür habe
die FDP etwa zu früh zu laut gejubelt
die neuen Brennstäbe waren das die
zentrale Forderung der FDP und damit ist
die umgefallen das hat sie nicht
durchsetzen können das ist nach meiner
Einschätzung abgestimmt gewesen zwischen
dem Bundeskanzler und dem
Bundesfinanzminister der weiß der wusste
von diesem Brief und hat ihn deswegen so
sehr schnell und sehr beflissen begrüßt
einfach um auch Kritik von der FDP
abzuwenden zu dieser Lesart passt dass
die Wut der Grünen ziemlich schnell
verraucht Schienen gestern noch Sprachen
viele von der France heute schon Klanges
angesichts des finalen atomaus im April
egal was der Winter bringt als hätte
auch die Empörung der Widerstand der
Fraktion eine eher kurze Restlaufzeit
ich glaube am Ende wird es so sein dass
wir das mehrheitlich tragen so hat die
Ampel nun eine Lösung produziert zu
jener Frage die seit März im Raum stand
sehr viel Reibung war dazu spüren sehr
wenig von jenem Geist der vor rund einem
Jahr beschworen wurde auch hierauf hieß
die Opposition heute ausführlich hin
dass der Kanzler den Treiben seiner
ego-shooter-minister jetzt mit der
sogenannten Richtlinienkompetenz ein
Ende bereitet hat ich finde der hat viel
zu lange etwas ungerührt zugeschaut und
da täuscht auch so ein sage ich jetzt
mal billiger Kompromiss überhaupt gar
nicht drüber hinweg dass wir da
eklatante Probleme in der
Regierungspolitik haben für das nächste
potenzielle Problem der Ampel hat heute
der Bundesrechnungshof gesorgt in einem
Schreiben an den Haushaltsausschuss das
dem ZDF vorliegt stuft er den
sogenannten doppelwumms als
verfassungswidrig ein denn die hierfür
geplanten Ausgaben gehörten in den
normalen Haushalten nicht wie von der
Ampel vorgesehen in einen nebentopf hier
den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds dies
verstoße gegen den verfassungsmäßigen
Grundsatz der Jährlichkeit übersetzt aus
dem Rechnungsprüfer Deutsch heißt das in
etwa Schluss mit tricksen so geht's
nicht
und der Bundesfinanzminister und
FDP-Chef ist uns aus Berlin zugeschaltet
guten Abend Herr Lindner guten Abend
Frau Slomka dann fange ich gleich mal
mit einer Frage an den Finanzminister an
mit der aktuellen Meldung heute dass der
Bundesrechnungshof sie rückt die Art wie
der doppelbums finanziert wird der sei
verfassungswidrig das ist ein ziemlich
heftiger Vorwurf was kontern sie darauf
der Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds ist ja ein
bestehendes Instrument das nutzen wir
jetzt für den Abwehrschirm von 200
Milliarden Euro bis zum Jahr 2024 ist
also eine geübte und ständige
Staatspraxis von der die Bundesregierung
sicher ist dass sie nicht nur
verfassungsrechtlich verantwortbar ist
sondern in diesen Zeiten auch ökonomisch
notwendig denn wir dürfen ja nicht
hinnehmen dass beispielsweise gesunde
Betriebe die Existenz verlieren oder
dass Menschen ihre Gastfamilie nicht
mehr bezahlen politische oder eine
wirtschaftspolitische Begründung aber
jetzt keine verfassungsrechtliche oder
haushaltsrechtliche also sie sagen der
Bundesrechnungshof dass der sagt das
verstößt gegen haushaltsgrundsätze dass
man Schulden sozusagen soweit im Voraus
oder Kredite auf Vorrat
aufnimmt sie sagen dass es Quatsch und
wir bleiben dabei und das hält auch
Stand ist eine ständige Staatspraxis ist
keine Erfindung der jetzigen
Bundesregierung oder von mir sondern das
wurde in der Vergangenheit auch so
praktiziert und im konkreten Fall geht
es ja genau um folgendes vor Slomka ich
möchte gerne für den regulären
Bundeshaushalt im nächsten Jahr zur
Schuldenbremse zurückkehren um dort die
Disziplin zu haben um auch den
Kapitalmärkten zu signalisieren
Deutschland bleibt Goldstandard bei der
Staatsfinanzierung wir werden auf Dauer
nicht den Marsch in die Verschuldung
eintreten und auf der anderen Seite
müssen wir krisenbedingt zweckgebundene
Maßnahmen finanzieren und das separiere
ich um deutlich zu machen wir trennen
das was die Krise von uns verlangt von
allgemeinen politischen wünschen und
Vorhaben kommen wir zu den politischen
wünschen und Vorhaben mit denen es in
letzter Zeit in der Ampel nicht so
richtig funktionierte
da ging es ja bei den Grünen um einen
echten Markenkern also um das was in der
DNA dieser Partei drin ist wenn es zum
Atomkraft geht ist das klug aus
fdp-sicht bei so einem Thema dann so ein
Punch zu erringen will ich mal sagen bei
dem es für einen selbst eigentlich nicht
um so viel geht jedenfalls nicht um
etwas was ihre Partei Geschichte prägt
und Wähler entscheidend ist
aber es geht etwas es geht um etwas für
unser Land wir sind in einem
energiekrieg und ich bin froh dass wir
jetzt für diesen Winter alles an
Stromerzeugung aus Kohle und aus
Kernenergie am Netz haben in der Tat das
war ein Prozess in den letzten Monaten
der war sehr schwerwiegend am Anfang gab
es gar kein Verständnis für überhaupt
nur ein Kernkraftwerk am Ende sind jetzt
befristet für diesen Winter alle drei
Kernkraftwerke am Netz und das eine gute
Nachricht denn wir stärken die
Stabilität der Stromnetze und wir senden
Signale aus die auch den Preis am
Strommarkt reduzieren können und das
wendet Schaden von unserem Land ab na
also ob das jetzt dieses eine
Atomkraftwerk in der Emsland das dann
drei Monate länger läuft ob das dann
wirklich den gesamten Strompreis im
Bundesgebiet senken wird das wird man
sehen daran gibt es Zweifel aber
unabhängig von dem inhaltlichen sie
wollten ja eigentlich viel mehr und
jetzt gibt es keine Brennstäbe es werden
keine neu gekauft und am 15 April endet
die dieser Sache was das wird dafür dann
einen solchen koalitionskraft zu
riskieren ich empfehle das nicht
parteipolitisch zu betrachten sondern
physikalisch dieses eine Kraftwerk von
dem sie gesprochen haben dass jetzt noch
dazu kam das sind immerhin 1,7 Terawatt
Leistung die produziert werden das ist
der Stromverbrauch einer Mittelstadt in
Deutschland und ein klares Signal war
erforderlich übrigens nicht nur an die
Menschen in Deutschland und unsere
Wirtschaft sondern auch nach Europa dass
wir wirklich alles in unserer Macht
stehende tun um Knappheiten am
Strommarkt zu beseitigen die Innenstädte
sind zur Sendezeit des heute Journals
dunkel weil Strom gespart wird in
solchen Zeiten kann man nicht auf eine
Kilowattstunde verzichten aber sie
wollten ja viel mehr sie wollten am
besten fünf sechs AKWs die bleiben und
sie wollten bis 2024 weil sie sagen im
Winter 23 24 ist das Problem ja noch
nicht vorbei
ich konzentriere mich jetzt auf diesen
Winter und in diesem Winter haben wir
alles an Kapazität an Kohle und an
Kernenergie am Netz das war nicht leicht
zu erringen in den letzten Wochen und
ich sag noch mals geht da nicht um eine
parteipolitische Frage sondern es geht
um Physik um Strom Erzeugungskapazität
ich jedenfalls bin kein Freund der
Kernenergie auf Dauer wir brauchen
Wasserstofftechnologie sauber sehr
wettbewerbsfähig wir brauchen die
sogenannten Erneuerbaren
freiheitsenergien wie ich sie nenne da
müssen wir jetzt Planungs und
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen wir
brauchen technologieoffenheit in dem
Bereich auch private Investitionen die
anderen Themen aber lassen uns doch noch
mal bei dem AKW bleiben sie haben selbst
gesagt wir brauchen für nach vorne
schauen ja bitte ja wir brauchen für 23
24 auch eine Lösung das war noch relativ
sanft formuliert anderen ihrer Partei
zum Beispiel der Kollege Kubicki oder
die Abgeordnete Adler die lassen
eigentlich schon durchblicken das ganze
kommt auch wieder Vorlage
ich habe auch den Bund der deutschen
Industrie heute gehört der ebenfalls
diese Debatte jetzt fortsetzen will ich
sehe es anders wir haben jetzt für
diesen Winter eine gute Lösung gefunden
die maximale Lösung wir gehen
gewissermaßen All-In alles an Kohle
alles an Kernkraft ist in diesem Winter
am Netz und damit zeigen wir den
Menschen wir tun das maximal mögliche
auch wenn es vielleicht parteipolitisch
schwierig herbeizuführen war und die
Bundesregierung wird nun alles in ihrer
Macht stehende tun Frau Slomka dass wir
im nächsten Winter eine solche Debatte
nicht noch einmal führen müssen weil wir
auf den Weltmärkten genug Flüssiggas
einkaufen weil wir die Kapazität an
stromproduktionen im Inland verbessern
also alles muss unternommen werden dass
wir eine solche Debatte gar nicht mehr
führen müssen weil sie sicher übrig hat
das ist ein klares Wort danke Ihnen Herr
Lindner für das Gespräch vielen Dank für
Ihr Interesse
in dem Krieg der uns in diese
Energiekrise gestürzt hat setzt Russland
Waffen aus Iran ein daran haben die
Ukraine und ihre Unterstützer keinen
Zweifel Moskau und Tehran haben ja auch
viele gemeinsame Interessen unter
anderem daran ihre Bevölkerungen
diktatorisch zu unterdrücken Putin
gelingt das nach wie vor auch wenn er
sich fragen muss wie gefährlich Ihnen
die zwangsmobilisierung hunderttausender
junger Männer wird vor allem wenn immer
mehr in Sergen aus der Ukraine
zurückkehren
das Regime in Iran hingegen sieht sich
mit einer Protestwelle derzeit
konfrontiert in der manche sogar schon
den Beginn einer Revolution sehen die
Furcht der Mulas ist jedenfalls
offenkundig groß besonders vor der
Wirkungskraft von Prominenten wirkmaß
rekerbiet hat das was sie liebt klettern
doch vorgestern bei den
Asienmeisterschaften in Südkorea tat sie
es für Irans Nationalmannschaft vor den
Augen der Welt ohne Kopftuch in diesen
Tagen ist diese Geste ein Politikum und
so lösten diese Bilder ein Erdbeben aus
in Internetforen wird Elenas rekerby
gefeiert als neue Helden der Proteste in
ihrer Heimat
heute Abend bei einer
Kulturveranstaltung in Teheran junge
Frauen zeigen sich offen ohne Kopftuch
und für viele hier steht fest dass auch
Elenas recy mit ihrem Auftritt ein
politisches Zeichen setzen wollte
sie hat das sehr gut gemacht und ich
hoffe dass noch mehr Sportlerinnen und
Sportler so etwas tun damit wir an der
Situation etwas ändern können
doch es dauerte nicht lange da trat die
Staatsmacht an die neue Helden zu
bestrafen oder zumindest zu entzaubern
auf ihrem instagram-account erschien
eine Entschuldigung es handelt sich um
ein Missverständnis sie habe den Sport
hi Jab ja tragen wollen alles seine
Verkettung unglücklicher Umstände dieses
mea culpa mag in Iran niemand glauben
auch nicht der renommierte Politik
Professor sadeck sie bei Kalam
vielleicht werden sie die Leute wegen
dieses Dementis noch mehr lieben denn es
ist klar dass sie unter Druck gesetzt
wurde das zu schreiben das wird ihr
vielleicht noch mehr Sympathien
einbringen Babyschuhe
Iran Sicherheitsorgane üben Druck aus
auf protestierende und alle die sich mit
ihnen solidarisieren sowie der Sänger
shavin hacipur sein Protestlied wurde
zum Hit eine Woche saß er in Haft wurde
auf Kaution entlassen ihm droht ein
Strafprozess doch er bleibt mutig ich
hoffe ihr versteht mich ich lebe in Iran
ich will in meiner Heimat bleiben will
hier leben und singen wenn ich etwas
kritisieren will dann will ich es hier
in die Hand tun
Strafen drohen auch prominenten
Schauspielerinnen wie katalon Riahi oder
Sportlern wie Fußballer adidai die die
Proteste im Internet unterstützten nun
also Elenas recavi morgen früh soll sie
mit dem Nationalteam nach Iran
zurückkehren vielleicht droht ihr Haft
vielleicht auch nur eine Pressekonferenz
auf der sie dann sagen wird dass sie nie
plante gegen die islamische
Kleiderordnung zu verstoßen
mit dem Blick in die Ukraine geht es
jetzt bei dir weiter Heinz ja dort hieß
es aus dem Präsidialamt in Kiew heute
das nach den russischen Angriffen auf
die strominfrastruktur die Lage im
ganzen Land kritisch sei man müssen sich
auf Ausfälle der Strom- und
Wasserversorgung sowie von Heizungen
einstellen nach Angaben des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski sind durch die
jüngsten russischen Luftschläge 30
Prozent der Elektrizitätswerke im Land
zerstört worden doch heute gab es in
Kiew wieder russischen Beschuss gezielt
auf Energieanlagen mindestens drei
Mitarbeiter sollen getötet worden sein
nach ukrainischen Angaben waren heute
mehr als 1100 Orte ohne Strom
und zum Krieg in der Ukraine gibt es in
unserem heute schon mal Update auch ein
Interview mit der nato-botschafterin der
USA Julian Smith sie sagt zu einem
möglichen Ende des Krieges unter anderem
es gebe ein Land das diesen Krieg heute
beenden können und das sei Russland das
Interview können Sie auch in der ZDF
Mediathek sehen
bundesinnenministerin Fräser hat den
Präsidenten des Bundesamtes für
Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik
Schönbohm von seinen Aufgaben entbunden
Hintergrund sind Vorwürfe das schönboom
Kontakte zu einem umstrittenen Verein
mit angeblichen Verbindungen zur
russischen Geheimdienstkreisen hatte wer
schön worum an der Spitze des BSI
nachfolgt ist noch offen
die EU-Kommission will in der
Energiekrise mit mehreren Maßnahmen die
Belastungen abmildern
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
schlägt vor ungenutzte EU-Mittel von 40
Milliarden Euro aus der
Regionalentwicklung jetzt für die
Entlastung von Unternehmern und Bürgern
zu verwenden außerdem sollen sich die
Mitgliedsstaaten und Energieunternehmen
künftig beim Gaseinkauf stärker
abstimmen und gemeinsam handeln
der Ärger über die hohe Inflation wächst
auch in Frankreich beim Generalstreik
der Gewerkschaften sind deshalb 10.000
Beschäftigte aus den unterschiedlichsten
Branchen nun für höhere Löhne auf die
Straße gegangen nur ein Teil der Bahnen
war heute in Betrieb auch in Schulen
wurde gestreikt seit drei Wochen läuft
bereits der Streik an den Ölraffinerie
der Regierung hatte die Beschäftigten
zuletzt zur Arbeit verpflichtet da der
Sprit an fast jeder dritten Tankstelle
knapp ist
in Nigeria haben laut Behörden rund 1,3
Millionen Menschen ihr Zuhause verloren
weil die Regenzeit bisher so heftig
ausfielt wie seit zehn Jahren nicht
weite Teile des Landes sind überschwemmt
bisher kamen durch die Wassermassen
mindestens 600 Menschen ums Leben
hunderttausende Hektar Ackerland sind
zerstört es droht eine Hungersnot und
auch die Angst vor Infektionskrankheiten
wächst und es soll weiter regnen
der Überfall Russlands auf seinen
Nachbarland hat auch ein fernen Osten
Entsetzen ausgelöst vor allem für Taiwan
war es ziemlich erschütternd zu sehen
dass ein mächtiger Nachbar es nicht bei
Drohungen und Säbelrasseln beläst
sondern überraschenderweise tatsächlich
angreift Menschen in Taiwan fragen sich
ob ihnen mit China ein ähnliches
Schicksal blüht
dass ich die Russen mit ihrer Invasion
gründlich verkalkuliert haben ist da
kein Trost das Leid und die Zerstörungen
und das Ungewisse Ende des Krieges lösen
auch in Taiwan Ängste aus jede Regung
Chinas wird mit Argusaugen beobachtet
Norman Odenthal berichtet aus Taiwan
die Arme ausgestreckt die Hände ruhig
Savannah lernt beängstigend schnell
der Gedanke dass ich im richtigen Leben
eine Waffe einsetzen könnte fühlt sich
unwirklich an
aber können sie sich denn vorstellen mit
einer echten Waffe auf einen Menschen zu
schießen
wenn ich müsste dann würde ich es tun
wenn ich müsste ja
um das zu lernen sind sie hier
trainieren den Ernstfall mit
Airsoftwaffen die Kunststoffkugeln
verschießen Spielzeug kann man das wohl
nicht mehr nennen Design Gewicht
Handling alles soll so echt wie möglich
sein und das Interesse an den Kursen
steigt
China droht immer wieder als werde
Taiwan angreifen wenn wir uns nicht
beugen und uns China anschließen dann
wenden Sie Gewalt an sagen sie das
jüngste Beispiel ist doch die Ukraine
die Leute haben den Feind nicht ernst
genommen sie haben nicht geglaubt dass
ein Krieg ausbricht aber es ist passiert
für das Airsoft Probetraining ist
taiwand bestens gerüstet 70% dieser
Druckluftwaffen werden hier hergestellt
in aller Welt exportiert aber zuletzt
hat eben gerade die heimische Nachfrage
merklich angezogen und auch hier in der
Fabrik ist das reale Kriegsszenario nie
weit weg
die Produktion unserer Airsoftwaffen ist
anspruchsvoller als die echter Waffen
Antrieb Aufbau und Struktur ist dir
komplizierter wenn wir eines Tages auf
die Produktion echter Waffen umstellen
müssten dann ginge das ganz schnell und
einfach
auch dieser Mann denkt an den Ernstfall
Robert Sao hat ein Vermögen in der Chip
Industrie gemacht satte 100 Millionen
Euro spendet er jetzt für die
Landesverteidigung finanziert Kurse zur
militärischen und medizinischen
Ausbildung von Zivilisten das viele
Taiwaner die Drohungen aus Peking noch
immer abtun macht ihn verrückt
die aktuelle Schwäche Taiwans besteht
nicht den Mangel an Waffen es fehlt
einen schlossen halt Chinas Propaganda
dröhnt zu uns gegenwärts zwecklos gibt
auf China ist viel zu mächtig für euch
das ist eine Lüge ich sage den Leuten
hier wacht auf und verteidigt eure
Nation
die hier sind schon hellwach jeden
Sonntag trifft sich die Gruppe macht aus
dem Parkhaus ein Schlachtfeld die
Ausrüstung professionell auch ihre
Airsoftwaffen sind kaum von echten zu
unterscheiden
ich begreife das hier als realen
Kriegseinsatz so gehe ich daran an
oberster Stelle steht dass ich und meine
Kameraden überlebt
ein Überlebenskampf heute im Parkhaus
morgen vielleicht draußen im warenleben
wenn es jemals soweit kommt dann wollen
sie ihre Insel verteidigen so gut wie
möglich
jetzt gibt es bei dir noch mal Heinz bei
dir noch mal weiter Heinz mit Wirtschaft
die Zahl der Baugenehmigungen für
Wohnungen ist weiter zurückgegangen das
Statistische Bundesamt meldet für August
ein Minus von mehr als 9% verglichen mit
dem Vorjahresmonat Frank Bethmann wie
ist die Einschätzung wie geht es weiter
mit dem Bauvolumen na derzeit deutet
nichts auf ein Ende des Abwärtstrends
hin jüngst hatten die
Wirtschaftsforscher des ifo-Instituts
von einer sich aufbauenden
stornierungswelle am Bau berichtet immer
mehr Bauherren ziehen die Reißleine weil
die Kosten einfach davonlaufen es
schlicht und ergreifend zu teuer wird
folgerichtig sinkt auch die Anzahl der
Genehmigungsverfahren besonders deutlich
der Rückgang bei den Einfamilienhäusern
hier macht sich zudem das Auslaufen des
baukindergeldes statistisch bemerkbar
weniger Baugenehmigung auch bei
Zweifamilienhäusern ein Anstieg dagegen
bei Mehrfamilienhäusern insgesamt wurden
von Januar bis August gut
244.000 Wohnungen genehmigt nur rund
244.000 muss man sagen denn die negative
Entwicklung ist ein weiterer Rückschlag
für die Bundesregierung die sich trotz
aller Probleme am Bau weiterhin das Ziel
von 400.000 neuen Wohnungen pro Jahr auf
die Fahne schreibt experten halten das
für unrealistisch fordern von der
Politik
Investitionsanreize damit die
Bautätigkeit nicht noch weiter abnimmt
die trübe Stimmung auf dem Häusermarkt
auf den DAX fährt sie heute nicht ab im
Gegenteil das deutsche Aktienbarometer
legt zu umfasst ein Prozent oder 117
Punkte Kursgewinne ja auch gestern schon
und doch bleiben die meisten der
Börsianer hier skeptisch noch sei das
nicht das viel zitierte Licht am Ende
des Tunnels Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
in Frankfurt hat der Prozess gegen
Oberbürgermeister Feldmann begonnen es
geht um den Vorwurf der vorteilsname im
Skandal um die lokale Arbeiterwohlfahrt
unter anderem um einen hochdotierten
Vertrag für Feldmanns damalige Partnerin
der ob sagte er wünsche sich einen
fairen Prozess und beteuerte seine
Unschuld gegen den SPD-Politiker läuft
derzeit auch ein Abwahlverfahren
bei den Tarifverhandlungen in der Chemie
und pharmaindustries eine Einigung
erzielt worden mehr als eine halbe
Million Beschäftigte bekommen
Lohnerhöhungen und Einmalzahlungen zu
Beginn des nächsten und des übernächsten
Jahres werden die Löhne um jeweils
3,25% angehoben hinzu kommen zwei
steuerfreie Sonderzahlungen von
insgesamt 3000 Euro
hoher Besuch heute in Frankfurt König
Felipe und seine Frau Königin Letizia
kamen um für royalen Glanz auf der
Frankfurter Buchmesse zu sorgen Spanien
ist dieses Jahr Gastland der Buchmesse
die uns zum ersten mal wieder seit zwei
corona-jahren wieder real und in alter
größer stattfindet
für die Zitat von Twickel wirft einen
Blick auf die neueste spanische
Literatur sie hat zwei katalanische
Autoren getroffen ein Altstar und einen
new cover
Barcelona Hauptstadt Kataloniens hier
sind Erfolgsautor Ildefonso Falcones und
popliterat Kiko am matt geboren beide
Katalanen bilden das Leben in dieser
Stadt literarisch ab
Falcones eigentlich Rechtsanwalt schrieb
mit 47 Jahren sein erstes Buch die
Kathedrale des Meeres verkaufte sich
millionenfach er schreibt spannend und
eingängig gilt als massentauglich stört
ihn das
ich liebe es
die kassabacio heute ein Museum
Falcones schildert in seinem aktuellen
700 seitenschmöker die Tränen der Welt
wie Antonio Gaudi einst das Haus in ein
Glanzstück des spanischen Jugendstils
dessen modernismo verwandelte in seinen
Romanen taucht falconis in die spanische
Geschichte ein diesmal um 1909 hier auf
dem Dach schuftet sein Romanheld ein
Keramiker durch ihn erfährt man von der
revolutionären Bewegung in Handwerk und
Kunst aber auch von dem kaum
vorstellbaren Elend das damals herrscht
Arbeiter werden ausgebeutet tausende
Kinder schlafen auf der Straße Frauen
kämpfen um ihre Rechte
falconis erzählt aus der Perspektive der
Arbeiter
durch Protagonisten aus den ärmeren
Schichten die kämpfen und schwere
Arbeiten erledigen müssen durch sie kann
der Leser sich viel besser in die
damalige Zeit hineinversetzen
Barcelona von ganz unten aus der Sicht
der sozial Schwächsten das ist auch der
Blickwinkel aus dem Kiko am matt erzählt
der pop-romancier ist nur 10 km vom
Zentrum Barcelonas in einem
Problemviertel aufgewachsen
na bloß hier rauszukommen du magst den
Ort an dem du aufgewachsen bist hast ihn
aber auch willst weg weil hier keine
Zukunft ist und doch bist du an diese
deine Welt gebunden
sein Roman erzählt aus der Perspektive
eines Jungen von der Entgleisung eines
Lebens
hochsensibel entwickelt der Tics wird
zum Außenseiter und findet längst
erwachsen und in psychiatrischer
Behandlung doch einen Gesprächspartner
ist das autobiographisch ich habe mir
das alles ausgedacht von wegen das
Viertel ist damals wie heute geprägt von
einer psychiatrischen Klinik Amazon
Mutter arbeitete hier als
hilfskrankenschwester
in meinen Büchern tauchen viele Leute
auf die sich Dinge einbilden aber sie
glauben daran um etwas das in ihnen
zerbrochen ist wiederzugewinnen das
Delirium ist dabei ihre Rettung
das ist doch abgefahren der Wahnsinn
rettet sie
selbst rettete wohl das Schreiben sein
Buch ist verstörend zärtlich und witzig
zugleich
kikoamat und
il defonso Falcones 2 Autodidakten deren
Romane Barcelona auf literarisch
unterschiedliche Art entdecken lassen
mir aber spanische Literatur und das
Gastland der Frankfurter Buchmesse
finden Sie auch in unserer ZDF Mediathek
in der Dokumentation Spanien lesen das
war es heute journal und gleich nach dem
Wetter folgt die Reportage Reihe 37 Grad
heute mit dem Titel jedes Wort ein Sieg
über stotternde die sich von ihren
sprechblockaden nicht aufhalten lassen
und damit Hunderttausenden anderen
Betroffenen Mut machen und um 0 Uhr gibt
es dann unser heute journal Update mit
einer göttingen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
Abend das ist Satellitenbild von heute
zeigt uns die Wolken einer
kaltfrontierquer über Deutschland und
die brachte uns teils ordentlichen Regen
30 bis 50 Liter pro Quadratmeter kamen
da zusammen im Tagesverlauf schob sie
sich immer weiter südwärts und wir sehen
von Westen her löste sie sich dann
allmählich auf und das liegt an einem
hoch dass sich aus dem Nordwesten nun zu
uns schiebt und uns morgen einen ruhigen
und trockenen Tag beschert erst am
Donnerstag greift dann dieses Tief mit
unbeständigem Wetter auf uns über so
gibt es dann heute Nacht die letzten
Schauer im Südosten die lassen rasch
nach sonst ist es teils bewölkt teils
klar und vor allem in der Mitte und im
Süden bilden sich dann gegen Norden
gegen Morgen teils dichte Nebelfelder
die Temperaturen sinken in der Nacht auf
12 bis 4 Grad wobei es dort am kühlsten
ist wo es am längsten aufklart morgen
steigen die Temperaturen dann zwischen
der Ostsee und dem Schwarzwald auf 12
bis 20 Grad und damit ist es etwas
kühler als heute da haben wir am
Oberrhein ja noch einmal 24 Grad
gemessen aber trotzdem ist es noch mild
bis sehr mild für diese Jahreszeit
Jahreszeiten typisch ist dann morgen
Vormittag aber der Nebel eben vor allem
in der Mitte und im Süden der sich noch
länger hält nachmittags heitert es mehr
und mehr auf und vor allem im Norden
zeigt sich die Sonne oft bis zum
Wochenende bleiben wir dann bei diesem
eher milden Temperaturniveau 12 bis 20
Grad am Donnerstag nähert sich dann von
Westen das unbeständige Wetter und zieht
dann erst am Samstag diese Schauer und
kurzen Gewitter Richtung Osten ab das
war es von uns